er ist neugierig spricht klug viel und
schnell und er reist alleine an die
enden der welt roger willemsen der
bekannte fernsehmann und autor villumsen
ihre lange reise begonnen auf einem
sterbebett tag herr steiner sie haben
reicht ja die begann an einem sterbebett
und zwar eigentlich war es ein kleiner
junge von fünf jahren der bei meiner
damaligen freundin auf der sterbe
station lag krebs hatte gesagt bekam
dass er sterben würde und etwa eine
viertelstunde nach dieser nachricht in
der tür steht und sagt mir ist
langweilig und ich lege mich auf das
bett dieses jungen mit dem rücken die
decke anschauen und sagen reisen wäre
und wir beginnen zu reisen und ich
erzähle ihm alles mögliche über die welt
die er nicht sehen wird immer mit dem
gedanken dass ich eigentlich ein
konjunktiv entwickelten das reisen das
heißt dass man eigentlich zuerst soll
die sagen zum schluss herr die punkte
vernetzen kann einer lebensreise ja wir
gucken immer retrospektive sagen bei
einem suizid jetzt hat alles eine innere
ordnung denn es endete in der absage ans
leben
und insofern ist die lebensreise
wahrscheinlich als organisierte reise
oder als sinnvoller reise nur von hinten
aus so zu betrachten und das wird ja
auch heißen dass wenn man quasi sein
leben nochmals anstatt dass man nicht
das leben das man gelebt hat gelebt hat
sondern dass man eigentlich diese
geschichte die man erzählt über dieses
leben gelebt hat ja ich glaube gut da
sagt dass es haben viele leute den mut
zu leben aber wenige ihr leben zu
erzählen weil dieses herstellen von
ordnung eine bestimmte form von gewalt
prinzip fast repräsentiert nämlich
fakten auszuschließen anderer
einzubeziehen
diese als bestimmen zu sehen die anderen
als flüchtig zu sehen und diese ordnung
ist eine erzählerische ordnung insofern
heißt es dem eigenen leben gegenüber zum
erzähler zu werden auch zu sagen ich
ordne hierarchisch an was war wichtig
was war unbedeutend
man könnte jedes leben komplett auf
lauter unterschiedlicher weise die
einzige möglichkeit zur erfindung seines
eigenen lebens systemen retrospektive
und ist in der erzählung dass man sich
sein eigenes leben erzählt so wie man es
geht
ahold und man wird in einen verwendung
zusammenhang eingelassen weil man ja
auch die privat mythologie dabei
betreibt nämlich zu sagt ich war ein
brüten das kind ich saß in einer wiese
ich blickte auf den dampf der
eisenbahnen ich sehnte mich nach der
welt das sage ich vielleicht nur deshalb
weil ich irgendwann ein buch geschrieben
habe dass die enden der welt ist aber
trotzdem es gibt auch eine ikonografie
der erinnerung also dass man plötzlich
weiß diese hügel linien die haben immer
etwas bedeutet wo immer ich in ländliche
zusammenhänge eingetreten bin habe ich
plötzlich mit der schwärmerei wieder
angefangen und gesagt das ist jenseits
davon was wäre wenn und dieses reisen
als ein den ort zu verlassen heisst auch
manchmal das leben verlassen wollen also
über alle grenzen hinaus reisen wollen
einer dieser für mich interessanten
punkte bei ihren in ihrer biografie
reise biografie erzählung biografie ist
der historische moment als sie 1994 fürs
zdf madonna interview taten und haben
einen kleinen arzt war gut was machen
sie denn wenn sie den eindruck gewinnen
sie machen überhaupt keinen eindruck auf
jemanden ich mache immer ein druck auf
die leute sind ziemlich selbstbewusst
nein ich besitze einfach eine starke
persönlichkeit
halten sie sich selbst für clever
selbstsicher gut riecht und absolut und
für eine gute briefe schreiben sind sie
ganz sicher sie sind misstrauisch
so haben sie ihren traummann beschrieben
also werden sie die ideale partie für
sich selbst
wir würden nur dauernd streiten nein
warum nicht
warum habe ich das gefühl als ob ich
gerade mit meinem psychiater rede
tut mir leid bin eben aus europa was war
ihre reaktion darauf bei madonna sind
sie mit ihrem psychiater in zimmer sind
ehrlich gesagt geht das sogar noch eine
stelle weiter da sage ich ich bin aus
europa und stelle vielleicht europäische
fragen und dann sagt sie ach ja meine
psychiaterin ist auch aus argentinien
und wir haben das zu hause immer wieder
zurückgespult wäre gedacht haben das
kann sie ihnen gesagt haben wobei man zu
ihrer ehrenrettung sagen muss sie hatte
evita damals noch nicht gedreht wusste
vielleicht noch nie exakt aber das ist
wirklich merkwürdig dass sie mir sehr
viel erloschener vorkam sehr viel kälter
sehr viel stärker am marketing
interessiert und dadurch abstriche an
der intelligenz machte ich hatte immer
gedacht die punkte mich aus ich bin der
niemals gewachsen und ich glaube dass
eigentlich der antwortende auch heute
immer die möglichkeit hat durch
ironisierung des gegenübers zu punkten
und letztlich die hoheit zu behalten das
tat sie da gar nicht aber diese diese
kluft zwischen europa und amerika hat
sie konnte sie nicht einordnen
nein sie war eher verunsichert und sie
war nicht auf der spur der radikalität
die ihr unterstellt habe also europa der
hinweis hat deshalb nicht falsch weil
europäer weniger an marketingfragen
weniger an der vermarktung von produkten
interessiert sind und sie war eine
produktlinie und sie wollte eigentlich
nur nach dem produkt gefragt werden und
bestmöglichen eindruck aber diese art
von verwirrung die madonna hat das war
ja natürlich damals in den 90er jahren
auch für das offizielle fernsehen schon
auch verwirklicht dass man nach so fragt
das war schon was
ariel sein ja das war ein wenig
ketzerisch vielleicht aber ich bin ja
wenn ich da öffentlich sitze und frage
der anwalt aller derer die fragen haben
und ich habe 50 prozent meiner fragen
auf der linie dessen zu stellen was ich
meinem zuschauer meiner zuschauerin
unterstelle in ihrer neugier und deren
agenten bin ich und dem fühle ich mich
verpflichtet und insofern ist manchmal
dieser etwas konfirmanden 80 charme mit
dem man gerade aus fragt und eine frage
abfeuert und sich einfach entwaffnen
lässt oder entwaffnet der gehört zu
einem guten interview dazu ebenso wie
dazugehört
dem zögern zuzusehen dem verlegen sein
dem nicht weiterwissen dem staunen dem
brüskiert werden dem alle diese dinge
sind das schöne fleisch der
kommunikation und das will ich sehen das
spiel glatt sind 19 790 einem ziemlich
bösen artikel über sie geschrieben
das heißt es vermutlich noch erinnern
dass er eigentlich sagen diesen diesem
internet das ende von williamson hätte
sich vollzogen
wie immer muss ich dem spiegel auch in
dieser hinsicht unrecht geben heute
gucke ich dieses interview an dass 28
minuten insgesamt war und muss sagen ich
kann es mir kaum ansehen aber ich
bestaune den jungen mann der den mut
gehabt hat immer und immer und immer
wieder wie eine beharrliche stubenfliege
gegen die wand zu bummeln und dasselbe
zu wollen und sie in irgendeinem
außenposten des radikalen zu erwischen
was mir nicht geglückt ist und ich finde
der spiegel hat sich auf sehr viel sagen
wir mal dienst fällige weise madonna
gegenüber schon verhalten als ich es in
dem fall getan habe insofern glaube ich
dass das eher ein gut geführtes
interview war auch wenn es qualvoll zu
sehen ist aber es heißt quasi man hat
sie des nazismus bezichtigt dass sie
eigentlich yamada missbrauchen für sich
selbst dass sie diese distanz abschaffen
zwischen ihnen und dem stahl um für sich
selber also das ist eine prämisse glaube
ich die sitzt auf einer falschen
voraussetzung nämlich wer allzu
interessiert daran ist das eigene bild
zu kontrollieren macht sich verrückt ich
habe im fernsehen ernsthaft nicht
besonders viel darüber nachgedacht wie
ich wirke weil ich sehr früh begriffen
habe ich kontrolliere meine bilder nicht
sie gehen atom ist ish in alle welt eben
es bleibt irgendwo irgendetwas hängen
von dem was wir hier sprechen wird
irgendein artikel irgendwo in den
schweizer bergen ankommen und vielleicht
bleiben aber wir werden beide nicht
kontrollieren können welche artikel das
ist und insofern habe ich das aufgegeben
wenn man sehr viel schreibt oder sendet
oder auf bühnen ist oder so dann muss
man in der hinsicht gelassen werden und
das war ich da auch schon also das heißt
wir sind es nicht gestorben sind 19 97
94 in diesem interview
sie haben etwa 2000 interviews gemacht
in der zwischenzeit den letzten 20
jahren habe ich gelesen da haben sie
schon deswegen diese viele fragerei das
ist ein genuines verhalten
also wenn sie mich so freundlicherweise
angekündigt haben mit der qualität der
neugier dann ist das etwas das nicht
tatsächlich vielleicht umtreibt zu sagen
wenn ich im taxi sitzt rede ich mit dem
taxifahrer über das taxifahren ich rede
gerne mit leuten über das worin sie
sachverständig sind und das liebe ich
liebe es aus der anschauung
informationen zu ziehen mich auf diese
weise zu bereichern
auch zu steigern auch zu konzentrieren
auch meine orientierung zu verbessern
auch mich in frage stellen zu lassen
also sind alles erregungen die mich aus
dem halbschlaf bringen aus der
materialermüdung aber diese erregung
könnte natürlich auch eine form von
ablenkung sein leben und des schweigens
und der introspektion und dass sie haben
einmal gesagt hat mir das zitat zwei
ausgeschieden ich bin redselig weil ich
etwas verhüllen will eine defizienz aber
ich will es nicht wissen also was dran
dann wollen sie wissen was ist sagen wir
mal so bei anderen frage ich mich sehr
genau wie viel aufmerksamkeit anspruch
hat die öffentlichkeit an bestimmte
themen es ist nun mal passiert in einem
interview dass sich eine namhafte
deutsche schauspielerin in die nähe
ihrer familiengeschichte geführt habe
und im interview nur an einem blick
gemerkt habe dass ihre mutter sich das
leben genommen hat und ich habe in
diesem augenblick entscheiden müssen ob
ich das zum thema machen will und frage
oder nicht und habe mich dagegen
entschieden
ich habe bis heute niemandem erzählt
wäre das auch nicht erzählen weil ich
entschieden habe dass die öffentlichkeit
keinen anspruch darauf hat wenn ich sage
meine eigene marke
die darin besteht dass ich gerne rede
dass ich gerne brücken schlagen zu
menschen dass ich schnell entflammbar
bin ja auch unreif auch halbstarke
auftrete auch zu drastisch formulieren
kann oder so die hat mit irgendetwas
kompensatorischen zu tun ich will nicht
wissen was das ist
ich will nicht wissen was die jaaa der
mangel ist der mich um trage ist es
wirklich interessante quasi zu sagen
diese eigene lebenslüge gehört zum
system und dieses system hat extrem viel
mit uns reden sprechen zu tun mit einem
permanenten auch sozial sein und in
einer niederschwellig kite und mit
dieser nieder schwierigkeit des
intellektuellen aber der sofort wechseln
kann zwischen hoher politik hohe kultur
bulva träsch fernsehsendung ja weil das
alles sind ja möglichkeiten diese
nährflüssigkeit der öffentlichen
informationen zu nutzen sie umzudeuten
sie sich an zu verwandeln
assimilation herzustellen das ja aber
auf der anderen seite sich nicht klar
darüber zu sein dass man durch mangel
geleitet wird durch dinge die fehlen und
dass die frage ist wie viel
öffentlichkeit will ich eigentlich und
wie viel bewusstheit will ich selbst auf
die quellen des mangels wenn das ist die
andere frage und an diesem punkt bin ich
nicht so sicher ich glaube obwohl wir in
einer philosophie sendung sitzen
dass man nicht nur nach der möglichkeit
von wahrheit fragen muss sondern auch
nach der funktion von wahrheit also
eigentlich eine ethische frage zu
stellen nämlich zu sagen wo nicht nur
wie es erkenntnis möglich sondern wozu
ist sie nötig jeder der schon mal ein
ehebruch begangen hat und sich überlegt
ob es sinnvoll ist das mitzuteilen wird
sich die frage gestellt haben welche
funktionen die wahrheit hat dafür noch
mal so ein bisschen bleiben das ist ja
nur erzählt diese diese soll sagen
vorsicht des gesprächs videos nicht
nicht eine grenze zu überschreiten
dieser grenze dran zu bleiben und auch
etwas interessantes von dieser
persönlichkeit zu holen ich habe den
selbstmord der eltern des vaters dieser
dame erzählt ihr eigener vater gestorben
als sie 15 waren die nähe des interviews
mit dem interviewten wenn sich das
überschneidet hat das etwas damit zu tun
dass man einen ein momentum findet wo
man selbst wo sie eine selbsterkenntnis
eben auch haben in dieser spanne drin
na ja das passiert weil alle guten
stücke von kommunikation haben etwas
unvorhersehbares und sie führen unter
umständen auf eine finale enthüllung und
an dieser enthüllung bin ich so
interessiert wie man gegenüber
trotzdem muss ich mich dann und wann
fragen was ist das für eine bühne auf
der ich sitze in welcher öffentlichkeit
kommt an was treibt die öffentlichkeit
mit diesen informationen es gibt formen
der selbsterforschung die gehirn in den
raum des intimen und die dürfen da auch
bleiben insofern werde ich mir von jeder
information die ich in umlauf bringe
in frage stellen mit welchem recht tun
das aber dieser bumerang-effekt quasi
als sie waren als junger mann
reiseführer und sehenswürdigkeiten
gezeigt sind sie mittlerweile auch so
eine art von sehenswürdigkeit geworden
das gehört damit zum spiel das man auch
sich zeigt ja und und wenn sie sagen es
gibt diese diese dieses unbewusste sie
wissen gar nicht europa will ist wissen
aber vielleicht durch das dass sie die
ganze welt kennen und alle menschen
kennen dieser welt kann man sie zusammen
stücken
ja es gibt ja unter den informationen
die ich versuche in umlauf zu bringen
einige von denen ich denke sie sind
notwendig also wenn ich die enden der
welt bereisen dann kann ich sagen an
allen enden der welt sehe ich den
rückzug von natur sehe ich das sterben
von natur sehe ich das ende der
schöpfung auch und das zu vermitteln
legitimiert zum teil das aufwändige
reisen an diese orte nicht alleine
aber auch das wäre die nächste instanz
eine qualität des blicks eines blicks
der sich weg wendet von der
sehenswürdigkeit und der in einer
situation ankommen will in einer
umarmung in einem duft also ein ganz
anderes ankommen hat das könnte den
zweck des reisens anders definieren also
bisher getan wird in dem augenblick wäre
vielleicht das unterwegssein das nicht
ankommen vielmehr reiseziel als das
ankommen so etwas zu vermitteln schiene
mehr an beiden polen der sachlichen
information und der formalen information
nicht unwichtig wenn man sie in anderen
kategorien sagen würde also zwischen
kälte und wärme madonna als einmal sogar
wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung habe
als kaltes stück fleisch bezeichnet sie
mir in diesem interview mir zu und sie
villumsen sind eigentlich er dann
vielleicht ein warmes stück fleisch
dagegen ich bin über wärmt ich bin
überhitzt ich bin manchmal hysterisch
obwohl höchste rat das wort für
gebärmutter ist also das kommt aus
meiner gebärmutter wenn ich so will das
jahr aber auf der anderen seite ist das
ja auch moralischer impuls ich verwahre
mich gegen madonna weil ich sage du bist
die bekannteste frau der welt zu diesem
zeitpunkt und das ist alles was du
anzubieten hast du hast keinen guten
gedanken in umlauf zu bringen
du hast keine überzeugung du hast nicht
so wenn du dir selber schaden würde ist
und das ist die voraussetzung für
courage ich habe ein experiment gemacht
in diesem winter
ich habe tina turner vor vielen jahren
mal die frage gestellt stellen sie sich
all die plakate vor auf denen siegel
aufgedruckt sind und sie könnten nachts
aus dem plakaten steigen und zu den
kindern gehen und ihnen eine botschaft
mit bringen welche botschaft wäre das
und tina turner hat wie eine gute alte
großmutter gesagt zieht euch warm an
verlasst euch aufnehmenden sorgt dass
ihr euch ernährt und so weiter und dann
habe ich nachdem ich madonna so kalt
fand aber ich gedacht stellt ihr
dieselbe frage und vergleich mal in
deinem kopf was sie sagt im vergleich zu
tina turner
madonna sagte es war ein mantra das kalt
unbelebt war das mit der welt der
jugendlichen die sich vorstellen sollte
nichts zu tun hatte und in diesen beiden
aggregatzuständen war sentimentalität
sehr sehr unterschiedlich aufbewahrt in
den beiden aber es kann natürlich auch
genau die kritik sein des spiegels zu
sagen also dass sie sehr sehr
schweizerdeutsch würde man heimlich weiß
sagen wir sehen sie das wort heimlich
heimlich und das ist ein ziemliches früh
wie möglich ist ein bisschen effekt oder
also dass man sagt dass man dass sie
sich anschleichen über ihre wärme an
diesen kalten eisblock madonna etwas wie
der psychiater oft zu öffnen versucht
und damit aber nicht das gegenüber
öffnen sondern ihre eigenen öffnung also
ihre sehnsucht ein bisschen wärme mit
madonna ebenso einfach recht wissen sie
madonna gehörte nie zu den figuren die
mir im leben viel bedeutet haben nicht
als institution nicht als
verwandlungskünstlerin nicht als
musikerin und es schien mir fast obszön
madonna warm kommen zu wollen was ich
machen will ist ein gutes gespräch ein
gutes gespräch müsste viele farben haben
ich hatte vor madonna zu riskieren hätte
sie zu amüsieren sie unbehaglich sie
aber auch behaglich vorzufinden sie zu
sanieren
ich habe zwei leute fragen gestellt ich
habe sie gefragt ob sie gut küssen kann
karriere gesagt ob sie auf fünf
verschiedene weise sagen können ich
liebe dich weil ich weiß dass sie auch
eine schauspielerin ist oder sein will
und sie hat das dann in fünf sprachen
immer gleich gesagt was ich relativ
witzlos fremd also
kann nur sagen dieses interview so lange
es her ist war wirklich so konzipiert
dass ich gedacht habe
eigentlich würde ich dass wir nicht die
courage hätte heute nochmal so führen
aber heute ist es jetzt nicht nein nein
ich finde sie heute eher ein licht wenn
sie sich den hintern hoch schnürt und
glaubt damit kann sie irgendwie auch ne
oder sieg ist jetzt dr dre von hinten
und der macht ein gesicht danach das
sind keine öffentlichen veranstaltung
die ich sehen will gut verlassen wir
madonna treffen aber was müssen das hier
natürlich wenn man videos von ihnen
anschaut ist das hier ein unglaubliches
gespür haben die fotografen würden sagen
für das momentum also für diesen einen
moment und etwas abzuholen das irgendwo
latenz da ist habe gibt es einen trick
ist eine technik für dieses momentum das
ist häufig von situation zu situation
unterschiedlich wenn mir arafat dreimal
hintereinander eine frage ablehnt weißig
wird das nicht zum vierten mal tun und
dann frage ich zum beispiel schreiben
sie noch gedichte und ich weiß er wird
jetzt irgendwo den anschein erwecken
wollen zugänglich zu sein und er greift
in die tasche holt ein notizbuch haus
und der beginnt in diesen notizbuch zu
blättern und ich sehe da ist auch
jährige eingetragen egal ob sie exakt
ist ob sie von e-mails es trägt auch zum
politischen bild von arafat wenig bei
aber es ist offenbar ein herrscher
gewesen wenn wir ihn so nennen wollen
ein präsident gewesen der lyrik schrieb
das war der moment in dem ich das gefühl
hat er etwas öffnet sich aber ich sage
auch dass seine waffe trug und sagte
tragen sie eine waffe und er sagt sehr
einsilbig wer selten war ja und ich sage
tragen sie sie weil sie sie brauchen
oder als symbol und er sagt beides sage
würden sie mit zeigen er sagt ein
präsident zeigt seine waffe nicht und
all das teilt etwas mit das ist nicht
mehr danach zu beurteilen ob ich in dem
augenblick kalt oder warm wäre sondern
es nur noch danach zu beurteilen ob
etwas zur erscheinung kommt am gegenüber
ich wollte einfach zwischen kalt und
warm sondern ist in eine reine eine eine
sanitär batterie herstellen
dieses missverhältnis genauso arbeit
also wenn man sagt dass sie einen moment
nicht hat das sehr viel mit vorbereitung
zu tun also ich glaube das ist etwas was
was ihnen sehr wichtig ist als dass man
vorbereitet im gespräch geht aber es hat
vielleicht eben auch mit der wärme des
kiefers zu tun wir uns also das heißt
der bauch
wenn sie diese diese schwingung eines
gesprächs aufnehmen müssen da brauchen
sie das hier nur zum teil ja weil ja
alle gespräche einen auch unter fordern
sie auch dieses gespräch weil wir immer
wissen in welchen linien wir nebenher
noch gedacht haben
also das ist ja etwas was wir in einer
partitur sehr in vielen stimmen
orchestriert ist und wir folgen einer
einer melodiestimme zb aber es könnte
sein dass man eine abzweigung nehmen
möchte ihn etwas was einem persönlich
sehr interessiert und was der eigenen
welt stärker entspricht und was
vernachlässigt wird also ich bin ja zu
einem teil jener öffentliche person die
sie als transmissionsriemen versteht für
alle jene die mit betrieben werden in
diesem indem sie diesen gespräch folgen
daran denke ich auch in diesem
augenblick es gibt diese momente fast
ich die schönsten für mich jetzt ich
habe jetzt stundenlang auf youtube ihre
interviews mehr angesagt
es gibt einen moment wo sie die die
dokumentation über über michel
petrucciani mit ihm zusammen anschauen
und berühmte der ist heute
geschäftsführer ist es in jazz pianist
und sie scheint sich das an und es ist
ein moment der totalen stille
das sind beide stumm und sie legen ihren
kopf an die schulter von bluttaten löst
diese emotionalität vermelden was so vor
sich her passt ist das vielleicht so ein
oder wahrsten fernsehmomente gewesen von
von ihnen das ist sehr reizen dass sie
das sagen denn diese szene hat noch nie
jemand so betrachtet und ich selber weiß
sofort was sie meinen wir sitzen in
meiner wohnung es ist morgens 3 uhr und
ich bin tatsächlich müde und ich lege
meinen kopf auf seine schulter und er
beginnt wie edith piaf zu singen in dem
er so irgend so etwas mal bricht diese
bricht die situation dass es genau
richtig beobachtet ja solche momente die
erscheinen vor kameras selten und sie
erscheinen auch nur in inszenierten
momenten sie haben irgendetwas genuines
etwas ursprüngliches ich erinnere mich
an den hauptdarsteller aus paris texas
von wim wenders harry dean stanton mit
dem ich nachts in los angeles in einer
bar sitze und die kameras sind an und
ich sage mitten im gespräch
sie sind allein und er beginnt zu weinen
und es war ein mann von dem man ahnen
konnte dass er nichts so wenig tun
wollte wie vor einer kamera zu weinen
und dann sagt er zu mir wissen sie woher
das kommt
und die peinlichkeit dieses trennen
flusses gleichzeitig die die situation
in der man keine frage gestellt sondern
eine aussage trifft die in einem
interview manchmal sehr beflügeln sein
kann
sie sind einsam das war ein moment den
man in der griechischen rhetorik heißt
das dann mehr häufig also als
geburtshelfer ein app eine stimmung
hervorbringt die dieser mann er zum
heimlichen zählen würde und die trotzdem
an diesem abend etwas warf die das über
ihn gesagt hat und dass sie vermutlich
auch über mich wahrscheinlich auch ja
ich hätte auch mit weinen können aber
sie haben es nicht gemacht
nein aber es war mir peinlich ich wollte
ihm diesem moment gerne ersparen ich
fand ihn trotzdem wahrhaftig und ich
habe ihn auch drin gelassen ich hatte
ihn herausschneiden können ich habe
andere momente aus dem gestell film habe
ich momente dieser acht rausgeschnitten
das ist das ist vielleicht noch einmal
kalt warm
der intellektuelle roger willemsen der
die intellektuellen bedürfnisse einer
fernsehgemeinde abholen kann bedienen
kann als scout voraus rennen kann um
diese atmosphäre des intellektuellen
intelligenten gesprächs herzustellen der
die wärme hat das aufzufangen damit es
in praktisch ist also auch fernseh
gericht ein ziel am fernsehen geht über
das nonverbale dieses gefühl über jahre
strahlung ist hat jemand angst oder und
das da gibt es dagegen so etwas was mich
auch irritiert hat eine alte freundin
von ihnen hat gesagt oder scheint gesagt
zu haben dass sie gerne karl kraus
gewesen wären oder während also der
berühmte boshafte publizist vom anfang
des jahrhunderts den alle gefürchteten
der aber gegen das verschmutzte der
seinerzeit gegen dieses künstliche
seinerzeit die großen werte der kunst
der literatur den krieg
die politik behandelt hat hat diese
freuen sich gehabt ich einfach den zwei
teilen der erste teil ist mir deshalb
wichtig weil es wenn es eine mission
gibt im bereich der kommunikation dann
wäre es die eine intelligenz des
gemischten gefühls zu betreiben und in
umlauf zu bringen das bedeutet wenn sie
mir sagen warm dann sage ich sofort
intellektuelle präzision kann sehr warm
sein in dem augenblick wo sie sich auf
einen leidenschaftlichen komplex bezieht
das heißt alles fühlen ist auch dann
besser wenn es intelligent gefüllt wird
und das heißt auch dass im kuss der ekel
enthalten sein kann oder das heimweh
oder der trennungsschmerz also dass
gefühle sehr selten eine c dur
dreiklänge sind insofern ist der
intelligente umgang mit dem was wir
effektiv nennen würden immer noch auch
etwas was ich dem warmen zu rechnen
würde oder dass in die mischbatterie
gehört jetzt kommt das zweite karl kraus
ist für mich deshalb eher eine
erzieherische figur gewesen weil der
moralist war und ich bin in dem sinne so
unpopulär der ausdruck ist auch moral
ist weil ich in anspruch nehme zu sagen
ich weiß an bestimmten stellen was sein
soll und was nicht sein soll
solange man das tut und das mit einer
gewissen stringenz vertritt wie das karl
gaus getan hat ist man tatsächlich
fundamentalistisch und man ist ungerecht
und man ist harsch und bringt sich um
vieles aber man vertritt eine sache die
noch abseits vom eigenen werten
wichtigkeit haben
dieses haus ist ja dann vielleicht nicht
so unbedingt den osten medientauglich
also auch ihr gefäß ist ja irgendwie
seine eine um definierte zone also zu
sagen ich mache massenmedium machen auch
unterhaltung mit einem minderheiten
irgendwo grund ist das überhaupt möglich
ich schütze mein lebensraum ich schütze
die meinen ich beanspruche artenschutz
für diejenigen die um den umgang mit
gefühlen auf eine bestimmte weise mit
kommunikation aber eine bestimmte weise
treiben wollen ich repräsentiere gegen
jene die nicht repräsentiert werden
also ich habe immer gefunden dass der
schöne begriff demokratie nicht
herrschaft der mehrheit wäre sondern
schutz der minderheit unter dem
protektorat der mehrheit insofern bin
ich jena wenn ich das so pathetisch
sagen kann der er für die
tritt die sich weniger repräsentiert
fühlen dass die ihre zwecke aufgeben
sollen dass die sagen wir haben in einem
massenmedium weil es um massen geht kein
recht mehr zu reden scheint mir eine
merkwürdig diktatorischen vorstellen was
also setzt natürlich dann die muskel
messlatte auch relativ hoch weil sie
sagen sie sind einfach ein
intellektueller
sie sind aber auch ein vorzeige
intellektuellen also der der
klassensprecher der intellektuell der
diese wärme vermitteln kann
jetzt müssen plötzlich dann auch alle
intellektuellen die diese wärme
vielleicht nicht so gut herstellen
können nicht so sind vom naturell her
irgendwie auch hinkriegen damit sie
überhaupt auf dieses niveau kommen um
wahrgenommen ich werde mich hüten
entweder ein intellektueller oder ein
vorzeige intellektueller zu sein oder
zumindest das für mich in anspruch zu
nehmen wenn es eine vernünftige
definition des intellektuellen gibt dann
ist es die eines menschen der ein hohes
verständnis vom umgang mit ideen hat mit
gedanken hat und der versucht
wirklichkeit durchlässig für gedanken zu
machen
natürlich repräsentiere ich damit
minderheiten aber dass sie nicht
vorkommen sollen dass sie nicht
erscheinen sollen oder dass es abfärbt
auf andere die viele intelligenter sind
als ich den bus auch im fernsehen ein
bester freund ist ein erheblich
intelligenter mensch als ich das scheint
mir so liegt legitim zu sein und
notwendig im gegenteil ich würde sagen
wenn diese stimmen aufhören wenn es
keine politische kritik wenn es keine
rhetorische moralische ästhetische
kritik innerhalb von massenmedien an dem
gibt was ohnehin geschieht dann ist das
das was die 60er jahre affirmation
genannt hätten also eigentlich einen
stillstand in der bestätigung und mit
der bejagung und ich komme nun in
deutschland aus einem land das eine
galionsfigur dass stillstand dass wir
ihn nach angela merkel pflegt und
insofern wäre es ja gerade nötig im
moment alle opposition und auch die des
intellektuellen des vermeintlichen zu
stärken statt zu sprechen aber sie
ziehen sich ein bisschen zurück aus dem
medium fernsehen den letzten jahren
ich würde mir und ihnen unangenehm wenn
ich überall da hingehen würde wo ich
eingeladen werde sondern ich bin sehr
viel mehr auf bühnen inzwischen und auf
bühnen habe ich das gefühl dass ich
erstens vor den menschen auftrete die
abendkarte lösen
um dahin zu kommen und zweitens ich kann
zu meinen bedingungen arbeiten und die
letzten projekte die ich gemacht habe
sei es mit dieter hildebrandt sei es mit
anke engelke
sei es mit der geigerin isabelle faust
die sind alle nicht fernsehtauglich dass
ein gutes stichwort gewesen also quasi
auf dem weg hin zum sollten zur stille
ist dieses programm mit isabelle faust
so 1 1 ein trampolin ins verschwinden
quasi oder in form von broadcastern
sparrow casting hinein weil sie über die
stille und die feinen töne das ruhige
diese zelebration herstellen die aber im
fernsehen wir das nicht gehen das muss
in einem kleinen jahr geschützt seien
eben theater eben also damit für
verstanden werden müsste man so sagen
ich habe mit dieser geigerin von der
viele sagen sie ist die beeindruckendste
dies auf der welt im augenblick gibt
von der habe ich bach einspielungen
gehört die zum teil in einem solchen
pianissimo raum spielen dass mir die
idee kam man müsste einmal schweigen
momente versammeln und man müsste die
leisesten stellen für solo-violine auf
textpassagen treffen lassen in denen
sich komplette stimme einstellt und man
müsste diese form der verdichtung als
ein angebot an das eigene still werden
der hörerschaft abend verstehen und dann
habe ich isabel gefragt wir sind
inzwischen sehr gut befreundet und wir
haben lange an diesem programm
gearbeitet die dinge so zu verzahnen
dass tatsächlich korrespondenzen
entstehen zwischen den gleisen zuständen
der musik und der texte und wenn man so
etwas macht dann hat das kein
kommerzielles interesse zu haben dann
ist das etwas das man macht weil es
hingabe es also die konzentration
also das heißt klar kann man das
argumentieren aber dass leise löst das
laute des fernsehens ab das und das und
sie sagen aber eigentlich in einer zeit
der kanzlerschaft von angela merkel
müsste man lauter werden und so wie sie
in den 19 jahren auf ihre art und weise
revolutionär im fernsehen laut geworden
plötzlich da waren plötzlich millionen
von menschen das wollten was williamson
kann es geht bis in die kleinen töne
hinausgeht weg ist nicht darum ihn
vermutet in isolation ein jahr lang im
bundestag auf der tribüne der
isolationshaft ist selbst ein buch kurve
zeigt dass wir sie ganz alleine 1 und
oben und andere leben sie schweigen oder
sie gehen auf
sie reisen weit weg alleine
also das ist schon ein bisschen
resignation vermutlich schauen sie es
gab drei projekte die autobiografisch
waren der knacks die enden der welt und
momentum und nach diesem projekt habe
ich gedacht das eigentlich für mich eine
trilogie nach diesem projekt habe ich
gedacht jetzt reicht s mal mit dem
autobiografischen ergründen von reise
sensationen und innenwelten so wichtig
mir das erst und der öffentlich
arbeitende autor setzt sich jetzt auf
die tribüne des deutschen bundestags was
noch nie jemand gemacht hat und sagt was
erschiene mir denn er nicht
tagespolitisch agierendem aktuell nicht
aktuell arbeiten denn was ist das
bleibende was ist das prinzipielle an
diesem parlament
das hat eine solche form von
diskussionen ausgelöst wir sind damit
bis im österreichischen parlament
aufgetreten das buch ist ein jahr lang
auf der bestsellerliste gewesen lauter
geht es kaum mehr ich habe so viele
politische diskussionen geführt damit in
parteien vertretern auf podien im
parlament und sofort dass ich sagen muss
jetzt reicht s mal mit dieser
ausschöpfung meiner öffentlichen aufgabe
wenn ich die den habe das ja nichts das
mache ich ja nicht aus masochismus und
ich mache es auch nicht aus hedonismus
mich auf die tribüne des bundestags zu
setzen dazu ist das wirklich zu
strapaziös
aber dann sagen es gibt ein ganz anderes
leben
daneben und das mache ich mit isabel zum
beispiel mit diesem schweigens 10
entspricht meinem inneren haushalt der
allerdings viel felder wirtschaft
bevorzugt das stimmt die die reisen also
diese die reisen an das ende an die
enden der welt das heißt für uns
schweizer die wir immer so ein bisschen
an der schule kleben ist das schon mal
interessant dass jemand wirklich dahin
geht um sich selber ein bild zu machen
das heißt ja sie reisen alleine auch
nämlich an um sich nicht ablenken zu
lassen um diese isolationshaft
auszuhalten die sie sich selber
funktionieren warum die enden der welt
die enden der welt sind ja erst mal eine
metapher für innere zustände sie stellen
sich plötzlich in einem bordell in
bombay ein wo ich durch einen flur
geführt werde und am ende des flurs
sitzt eine 18 jährige prostituierte die
sowohl schwachsinnig wie aids krank ist
um die zu den letzten exemplaren
eigentlich der letzten
klasse der untersten klasse der
menschheit gehören weil sie nur noch
kunden hat die ihrerseits aids infiziert
sind und so können die dann noch die
freuden der liebe wie man hier ohne
schlagen müsste empfinden oder erfahren
und an dieser stelle in diesem flur
stellt sich mir das gefühl ein es geht
nicht tiefer es geht nicht weiter ist es
gibt kein jenseits zu diesen existenz
zustand der fast anorganisch ist und
insofern ist das ein symbolischer
zustand der nordpol war ein weniger
symbolischer der ist ein
identifizierbarer patagonien ist ein
geografisch identifizierbare auch wenn
man in timbuktu ist und guckt auf die
sahara und man weiß das ist eine
todeszone hier endet etwas hier endet
auch die zustimmung zur belebten
existenz tritt etwas lebens verneinen
dass ein
dann hat man das gefühl es manifestiert
sich das ende der welt irgendwie aber an
jedem ende der welt über etwas
nachzudenken was und charakter hat das
ende der liebe das ende der sprache das
ende der schöpfung das ende der moral
alle diese dinge
das schien mir wert zu sein zu
unternehmen und eben nicht nur ich
allein ich hatte den eindruck bei der
lektüre des buches gibt zwei trigger
zwei treiber also das eine ist wirklich
dieses ende der welt und dann dieser an
diesen enden der welt wird alles
unheimlich oder heimlich oder oder
versteckt klandestin es gibt keine
bilder
wir mussten zonen also auch auch einmal
ein interessanter aspekt dass das gibt
dann vielleicht noch sprache und dann
hört diese sprach dabei auch irgendwo
auftreten was sie aber eigentlich
interessiert ist eben dass hinter dem
zürcher fiel in den besten geschichten
wird gestorben oder ist der tod ist eine
stewardess die sich ins eismeer wirft
auf dieser reise oder ist dein eine tote
einbalsamierte frau dahinter wie sie
dieses dahinter ausgaben ist gesehen wie
sie ganz richtig sagen das erste ist es
ist nicht fotografie aber es gibt nichts
darin was man anders festhalten könnte
als durch stimmungen manchmal
literarisch manchmal vielleicht
musikalisch manifestiert die begegnung
mit dem tod an
in diesen orten war ja keine die ich
gesucht habe oder die hätte inszenieren
können die geschichten sind ja zum teil
auf eine unwahrscheinliche weise real
gewesen sie haben mich ereilt sie sie
sind mir zu gestoßen und sie haben aber
gleichzeitig etwas von der banalität des
nicht seins auch enthüllt denn wenn sie
in nord indonesien irgendwo in einer
dschungel hütte liegen und jemand sagt
ihnen nachts um zwei und möchten sich
meine großmutter kennenlernen und ich
sage gerne und nehme die kerze auf dem
tiegel und gehe in das nebenzimmer
unterliegt diese großmutter und ist seit
einem halben jahr tot und wartet darauf
dass bullen geschlachtet werden für sie
aber das geld ist noch nicht da für die
bullen so ist ihre seele im jenseits zu
arm und dann stehe ich vor diesem
eingefallenen bei sanierten körper und
sehe dies in die ewigkeit starrende
gesicht das parlament farben aussieht
dann ist das nichts was ich gerufen habe
dann ist es eher wie wären wären starker
klang der plötzlich in dieser geschichte
schlummerte und ob schon bin ich mich
richtig erinnere
diese reise von einem freund johannes
und ja natürlich
der tod und symbole sammelt er es ja
diese dürfen schlacht geschieht ja darf
man ja wo sie dann also das stimmt nicht
so ganz also die dieses dieses
hineinstolpern ist also inszenieren nein
nein
an der stelle tatsächlich entschieden
nein ich reise los und verabschiede mich
mit einem von einem freund der etwas
älter ist als ich und der immer die
kreatürlichen funktionen des leibes sehr
geschätzt hat das rülpsen das furzen das
überschlafen das besamen all das tut mir
leid aber so war es und ich reise nach
asien und ich vollziehe eine reise in
der ich in mehreren stationen permanente
berührung habe mit genau dem schlachten
der büffel dem kotzen der passagiere in
einem reisebus der die ganze nacht fährt
in der nacht über fahren wir jemanden
der wird nur an den straßenrand gelegt
weil wir man ihn gerade nicht entsorgen
kann und ich komme nach surabaya gehe
auf die post er ist ante stelle für die
post lagernden briefe und ich nehme 23
briefe zu meinem geburtstag ins hotel
lege mich in das hotel habe endlich ein
gutes hotel der letzte brief den ich auf
macht es der von zwei guten freunden von
mir aus
und er ist eine todesanzeige und diese
todesanzeige betrifft den mann den ich
verlassen hatte der die kreatürlichen
funktionen so mochte jetzt kann man
sagen
ganz am anfang unseres gesprächs haben
wir davon gesprochen wie man eine reise
deutet im nachhinein
jetzt kann ich sagen alle diese elemente
die diese reise vielmehr bestimmt haben
als andere reisen
der tod des mannes das rösten dass alle
diese dinge werden plötzlich von einem
fluchtpunkt zusammengehalten der die
todesnachricht meines freundes handelns
gewesen ist und das hat der geschichte
am ende der direktive gegeben ich kann
aber nicht sagen dass ich während der
reise diesem moment hätte suchen können
sondern sie sind mit zu gestoßen und sie
haben sich später in dieser logik
entpuppt aber also so wie wenn man noch
der tod ihres vaters mit 15
also irgendwie muss das ja etwas
ausgelöst habe und auch für diesen
lebensweg und wenn man jetzt versucht
vom spielplatz auf diesen trend hin zu
gehen und dass man merkt dass hier das
schicksal zuschlägt
samsung ist nicht dass nicht jede
geschichte ist eine geschichte kassiert
ist mit ihnen und das quasi dieser tod
ein ein moment ist immer wieder
auftaucht eben hin zum tod zu gehen und
so etwas interessiert zu sein die
neugierde diese dieser dieser treiben
sie haben das was ist nach dem tod und
nach dem tod das sind sie nach dem tod
ist das was sie dann von hinten
anschauen können und sie haben das
einmal so beschrieben dass wir das ist
ein gewebe wie eine tapisserie die man
von hinten anschauen wenn man das
geknüpft ist ja also diese diese bilder
dieses rüber schwenken ist etwas was sie
was die antrags und dann diese gefahren
also dass sie in bangkok war das glaube
ich sich einen leistenbruch operieren
lassen also dass man das ist schon
gesucht das sieht das ja bewusst hin
gegangen das heißt dass die
aufgenommenen zeiten auch nach
deutschland repariert werden können und
leistung muss aber dass das diese nahtod
erfahrungen quasi die eigenen die
delegierten ein ein wichtiges motiv sind
sicher auch bei ihren afghanistan reisen
sie haben vollkommen recht dass wir
jetzt falsch wenn ich nicht sagen würde
sie haben vollkommen recht
es gibt eine bewegung des reisens wie am
anfang gesagt
die geht über alle horizonte hinaus und
will eigentlich aus dem leben raus und
die ist angezogen von den momenten in
denen man meint dieses leben wie auf der
rückseite der tapisserie sehen zu können
das stimmt und insofern ist an der
stelle immer das einfrieren von
geschichten in einem todesfall etwas das
die dinge abschließt und betrachter
macht man könnte auch sagen sie
objektiviert der tod hat an der stelle
etwas was in der kategorie des
endgültigen allem widerspricht was die
reise sonst auszeichnet die reise ist
immer dran sind die reise geht immer
weiter
sie geht innerlich nie zu ende und an
dieser stelle ist zuende dieter
hildebrandt stirbt und ich sterbe in
diesem augenblick mit weil so viele
erinnerungen nur noch durch das
trägermedium dieter in meinem leben
existiert und jetzt existiert es in mir
ganz alleine weiter und er fehlt jeden
tag ich kann sagen ich kann das
empfinden wie ich eine wunde empfinde
die nicht halt und da in meinem leben
ungewöhnlich viele leute bereits
gestorben sind und zwar gerade komplizen
gerade freunde mit sie sind aufgezeigt
dahinter platzierten viel milde brand
aufgetreten sieben jahre lang oder mit
volker kriegel zum beispiel der auch
vorstand mit michelle petrochemie lauter
menschen die mich wirklich mitbestimmt
haben und zu denen ich ihn sehr manchmal
so nacht iges verhältnis hatte wie
zuletzt von volker kriegel tragen sie
die schule haben es stimmt also seine
witwe macht irgendwann die schränke auf
und sagt welche schuhgröße hast du
eigentlich und ich sage zwischen 45 und
46 und sie macht drei schubladen aus und
volker hatte nagelneuer englische und
amerikanische studie dieser größen und
jetzt sind sie alle bei mir und ich
werde bis zum lebensende keine eigenen
schule mehr tragen müssen und da habe
ich immer das gefühl ich gebe vollgas
führen ja aber weisen für die die
bleiben ist natürlich auch heißen
verschwinden der da geht der geht weg
also dieses jahr quasi dieses todesspiel
weg ja sein und vielleicht wirklich am
konkreten beispiel von afghanistan
das ist ihre heißen nach afghanistan
reist man nach afghanistan
ich reise erst mal an der seite meiner
lieben exil afghanischen freundin nadine
nach ihr
es ist die erste vorsitzende des
afghanischen frauenvereins dessen
schirmherr ich wiederum bin das heißt
ich bin auch gebundene hilfsprojekte vor
allem brunnenbau und in schulen bau vor
allem für mädchen und preise die mit ihr
ich bereise sie auch mit einem cousin
von ihr der gewissermaßen der
sicherheitsbeauftragte für mich ist um
der versucht meine wege so sicher wie
möglich zu machen und ich reise dann mit
fahrern von denen wir wissen wer es ist
wir müssen einfach sicher sein können
dass sie keiner politischen gruppierung
angehören die unheimlich ist unheimlich
im moment haben sie sich erlebt in
dieser zeit ja in afghanistan ist die
gefahr so omnipräsent dass sie gar nicht
mehr von einem ereignis sagen können da
war ich in gefahr
ich bin mal im hauptquartier der taliban
gewesen weil ich ein gespräch führen
wollte mit einem häftling sprecher aus
guantanamo und als wir nach vielen
stunden aus diesem hauptfach herauskam
und ich glaube die taliban haben einfach
nur geglaubt einfach mir geglaubt dass
ich dieses gespräch so eins zu eins
drucken werde wie ich es geführt habe
und so habe ich es auch gedruckt die
haben sich in dem augenblick als weg
gingen überlegt ob das eine gute idee
ist und da sagt dann hat ja nur
plötzlich rogall auflauf oder auflauf
und ich sagte immer das gespräch war so
gut hast du gemacht und gesagt der lauf
lauf lauf und und ich konnte diesen coup
kaum verlassen indem ich war weil ich
noch so sehr in dem gespräch war aber
das war eine bedrohliche situation aber
natürlich sie kommen an orten vorbei wo
einen tag vorher oder einen tag später
neun menschen einer bombendetonation zum
opfer fallen oder sie werden bei seite
gerissen weil sie oben am straßenrand
stehen und wo urinieren wollen und
werden weggerissen weil deine mine ist
die sie nicht gesehen haben und insofern
sind sie kontinuierlich konfrontiert
damit sie sehen ein kleines windschiefes
mädchen steht auf weil es total gerufen
wird und hat nur einen arm und so
erklärt sich dass das windschiefe screen
werden die afghanistan im moment nicht
bereisen können ohne permanent
konfrontiert zu sein mit mit tod und mit
verlust sie kommen in ein ort der heißt
massenmord weil im krieg die männer aus
zogen und kamen zurück und alle frauen
und kinder waren tot unternahm die
männer entschieden dass sie da weiter
wohnen bleiben werden dass
der ort aber künftig massenmord heißt
das ist dann ihre postalische art
zuhause angst um sie doch es gibt und
ich wenn ich eine familie hätte und vor
allem wenn ich kinder hätte würde ich
ganz bestimmt afghanistan nicht bereisen
weil ich das niemandem zumuten würde
aber so bin ich wirklich mehr
verantwortlich und ich kann das soweit
schultern und es ist auch schon zwei mal
vorgekommen dass ich ein visum schon
hatte und ob es wieder zurückgegeben
weil es zu gefährlich war und vor wahlen
ist die sicherheitslage in afghanistan
immer sehr bedenklich aber also diese
weise ein bisschen angesehen sie haben
eine mission wenn sie nach afghanistan
gehen sie gehen nicht als tourist nein
ich kann den touristen nicht ganz aus
mir befreien wenn man tourist sein kann
in afghanistan weil alles was die
netzhaut belichtet so bereichernd ist
und weil ich stelle mir vor juri steiner
würde jetzt nach afghanistan gehen sie
würden ein land treffen
das beginnt nach einer 30 jährigen
kriegs zeit zu fragen was macht man
eigentlich mit frieden und das würde sie
sehr interessieren weil sie plötzlich
sagen müssen wie tröstet man sie liebt
man wie amüsiert man die begehrt man
welche formen der öffentlichen
geselligkeit kann es geben wie unterhält
man sich alles das was wir hässlich
kulturtechnik nehmen muss aus den
grundlagen der kultur wieder befreit und
entwickelt werden
das ist für jeden betrachter einen
staunenswerter vorgang an so etwas
teilzunehmen hier aber auf der anderen
seite steht die ganz normale und
organisatorische hilfe von der ich nur
sagen kann ich kann mich nicht für
helden in einem buch interessieren und
alle empathie für sie aufwenden ohne
diese empathie lebenden menschen
entgegen zu bringen wie beispielsweise
in afghanistan
also das heißt kunst und leben oder
literatur und leben müssen eine
in eine relation kommen wo die
glaubwürdigkeit die literatur über das
leben auch natürlich geben wir stellen
sie sich mal vor was das für eine
arbeitsteilige innerlichkeit wäre wenn
ich sagen würde
madame bovary erschüttert mich die der
suizid von madame bovary gut zum
schrecklichsten und dann kommen sie nach
afghanistan und sie sind in einer klasse
und sie können jedes dieser mädchen
gesichter verfolgen in eine bestimmte
leidensgeschichte sie können sich auch
die geschichten weiter erzählen lassen
aber die physiologische intelligent sagt
ihnen schon ganz alleine wie durchlässig
das ist was doch zu sehen und es und wie
leidvoll das ist und jetzt zu sagen
dafür habe ich keine empathie
das bringe ich nicht auf also das ist
gar nicht ruhig das ist mir nicht
gegeben sondern das erste was man fragt
nachdem ich das land so erschüttert da
war was kann ich tun
wie kann man und also könnte das sein
dass das ist eine eine korrespondenz
krieg zum thema soll nun anfang
besprochen haben nämlich dieses ich will
es gar nicht wissen über mich selbst
aber ich wäre bei den anderen wissen und
überdies ist von den anderen wissen
erfahre ich dann irgendwo vielleicht
dieser dieser großen vermenge lagerung
sehr viel doch über mich haben sich
nämlich über den selbstmord in der
literatur interessiert und eine hubble
begonnen und quasi der selbstmorde
literatur da sind wir an diesem genauen
punkt zwischen leben und kunst ja und
das heißt ihr eigener sozialer moment
nach afghanistan zu gehen bei den
taliban interviews zu führen also wo man
sagt das schon ein bisschen auch ein
risiko das sie suchen dass das was da
drin ist dass sie eine biografie gewählt
haben eben keine kinder zu haben keine
vater haben sie angst haben müssen die
sich vielleicht daran hindern hin zu
gehen dass sie dieses dieses spiel
zwischen kunst und leben gelebtem leben
anderen leben eigenen leben fremden
leben das leben an und für sich
in dieser tod ist auffahrten drin immer
wieder am besten
nun ja ich weiß
nun würde ich ihnen natürlich antworten
müssen nein ich nehme den tod in kauf
ich nehme die gefahr in kauf ich suche
sie nicht ich bin kein kriegsreporter
der an die front geht damit der
abenteuer erlebt und wenn sie texte dazu
sehen dann sehen sie dass ich immer
meinen
ich an der stelle möglichst weit
erlöschen lassen und zum verschwinden
bringen weil mich das nicht interessiert
der heroismus dessen der sich an einer
gefahr begibt sondern auch lustig der
schuld hat etwas gefallen hat diese
ganzen ernsthaftigkeit und tragik die
sie als auch geschildert haben ist das 2
2 auf gar nicht sehr jungs ja wenn sie
zweifel genau also der der steht da im
flüchtlingscamp und sagt hello mister
und dann sagt man no matter what are you
doing
ich sage just be sitting und daraufhin
dritter sie um zu seinem freund zu sein
schlug vors tor ist und das war
tatsächlich ja das war tatsächlich für
ihn nicht nur hoffnungs perspektive dass
leute kommen konnte
die plötzlich als touristen kommen aber
wissen sie noch bedenklicher ist die von
ihnen angesprochene schwelle zwischen
dem reden und dem schweigen dem
veröffentlichen von heimlichem ist ja in
afghanistan viel rigider denn wenn ich
dort einen dorfältesten frage wann
glauben sie denn gibt es frieden dann
sagt er wissen sie ich mache mir sorgen
um eine lobby ich habe das gefühl dass
vielen will auch nicht mehr richtig
fressen und dann denke ich aha die frage
ist zu zudringlich darf dann nach einer
halben stunde noch mal stellen und die
stelle sie nach einer halben stunde
anders formuliert noch mal und wenn sie
sich daran orientieren wollen wie die
weltpolitik ist glauben sie wir werden
bald ihr frieden erleben und er wird
wieder abschweifen und irgendwann sagt
er dann ihr habt die uhr wir haben die
zeit und es wird nicht ausdrücklich und
hätte diese dezenz im umgang mit dem was
persönliche nachricht ist persönliche
stellung ist dies in afghanistan noch
noch viel ausgeprägter als hier
apropos hier und apropos lizenz und
apropos zeit wenn ein deutscher die
schweiz bereits mit reis dazu dass die
schweiz sehr viel mit der bahn weil das
ja gute schweizer bahnen gibt und ich
die verkehrsmittel immer gerne mag bei
denen ich viel verbindung habe zu denen
die an der strecke wohnen und rein und
raus kommen und waren mitbringen oder so
das mag ich gerne irgendwann wird in den
bergen häufig langsamer gefahren ich
besitze keinen führerschein
insofern bleibt mir nichts anderes übrig
als in der regel bahn zu fahren und das
ist meine freude
aber sie haben doch auch schon sich
kritisch geäußert es gibt in der in der
schweiz eine zeit lang eine so sagen wir
mal schlicht formulierte
deutschenfeindlichkeit die mich deshalb
riskiert weil ich selber unablässig zur
kritik der deutschen auftrete auch mit
vielen eigenschaften die sie in der
schweiz immer wieder zeigen aber
kombiniert aus einem
minderwertigkeitsgefühl das irgendwie
sagt eigentlich ist das der spitze der
immer nur einmal unterm sofa vorkommt
einmal beißt und dann wieder zurück geht
und dann alle nationalen stereotypen in
umlauf bringt das ist nicht
intelligenter als rassismus anderer acht
man kann sich mit den deutschen wirklich
und man sollte sich dringend mit ihnen
anlegen aber man muss es intelligent
machen als alte nationale vorteile zu
beerben das wird der realität nicht
gerecht
einen kleinen sprung vielleicht also sie
werden dieses jahr 60
so ist es und ich habe einen artikel
lesen über einen besuch von ihnen in
winterthur letzten dezember und der text
schildert wie sie mühsam gehen durch
natur gewesen ruhe brauchen eben dass
sie fremde schuhe tragen und man hat das
bilder kommen eines alten ja ein
bisschen in der globalisierung zu ihm
steckt wie herrlich wildes und dass das
hat dann auch gepasst zu einem anderen
staat und von ihr dass sie gesagt haben
jetzt bin ich so viel gereist hat ein
buch geschrieben und das quasi jetzt da
airbus des reisens und des schreibens
auch so ein bisschen erlöscht muss man
sich ein bisschen sorgen machen um den
alten überwiegen bitte machen sie sich
sorgen
es würde mir so viel besser gefallen
wenn ich zu hause bin und weiß mehr
juri steiner macht sich sorgen um mich
lokalisierung ist wunderbares die
nächste privaten mythologie also gerade
öffentlich trete ich immer gerne im
bereich von mythen auf und jetzt könnte
ich sagen ja die materialermüdung ist
auch an mir nicht vorübergegangen
ich kann einfach nicht mehr so
problemlos in kamtschatka ein vulkan
besteigen wie ich das vor jahren konnte
oder durch lebens dazu spazieren winter
durch schaffe ich noch ich bin sehr
überrascht dass die journalistin gemeint
hat ich sei so erschöpft aber das muss
wohl so gewesen sein auf der bühne bin
ich dann wieder blühend hoffentlich ich
glaube auch dass ich eher so den
eine pfadfinder anmutung für mich in
anspruch nehmen kann
aber es kann natürlich sein dass ich in
winterthur erloschen war und das lag
nicht an winterthur ganz gewiss nicht
aber ich bin sonst was mein eigenes
altern angeht einigermaßen naiv und sehe
da keine dramen auf mich zukommen
jedenfalls noch nicht noch mache ich
alles halbstarker waren einige fahrer
die ihm so ein bisschen bei
intellektuellen auch häufig existiert
ist nämlich dass man im alters ein
bisschen alter straßen entwickelt und
mir ist aufgefallen dass sie den
gleichen geburtstag haben wie napoleon
bonaparte bis fanta august und sehen sie
da ein bisschen analogien
wissen sie ich glaube auch geburtstag
von matthias claudius oder princess
margaret oder walter scott dem
romanautor oder oscar peterson und ich
finde wenn man das kaleidoskopische
zusammennimmt oder tee lorenz dann ist
napoleon mir nicht der nächste von allen
also einfach bei mir dann doch bestimmte
vorgänge des transzendieren noch mehr
liegen und weil ich auch alessandra
länder nicht eindringen um sich zu
unterwerfen aber der der warme roger
willemsen über eine seiner fünf
rechthaberei sich auch immer mehr als
ein bisschen positioniert habe ich den
eindruck in streitgesprächen eben im
politischen drin also dass sie in
afghanistan oder über afghanistan die
deutsche rolle in afghanistan
dieses thema eine eine dezidierte rolle
haben die man wo man schon ein bisschen
überrascht ist denkt man also ich habe
das ja viel gemacht weil ich neun jahre
lang als kolumnist für die woche
gearbeitet habe und da eigentlich in
jeder woche eine polemische
auseinandersetzung mit tagespolitik
betrieben habe aber ich muss sagen das
ist ja eine vitalfunktionen dass man
sagt ich bin nun mal für dieses land
sachverständig ich bin da oft genug
gewesen anders als politisches personal
sitze ich in den ältesten raten ich
sitze in den privathäusern ich bin bei
den familienfesten ich bin nicht
geschützt ich trete nicht mit panzer
bester auf und ich gehöre nicht zu jedem
prominenten die eigentlich immer nur
einen soldaten camp besucht haben und
glauben deshalb keinen sinn afghanistan
und dann ist es ja die aufgabe dessen
der sich öffentlich artikulieren kann zu
sagen was ist meine expertise und ich
würde an dieser stelle gerne den
sachverstand des autos in anspruch
nehmen und der sagt das engagement der
deutschen in afghanistan ist fatal und
das was dort als resultat zurückgelassen
wird ist schlimmer als alles was es
vorher dort gab das machen wir erst mal
zur kenntnis nehmen und dann muss man
sich damit auseinandersetzen
aber die humanitären absichten unter
denen angeblich in afghanistan
einmarschiert worden ist und in der
immer noch bomben fliegen im augenblick
oder auch guantanamo herumzureisen und
die häftlinge aufzusuchen die entlassen
wurden mit denen gespräche zu führen
das sind ja gewissermaßen dependancen
der arbeit dessen der das fragenstellen
und schreiben irgendwann einmal erlernt
und als seine passion entdeckt hat also
da trete ich ja dann für einen
öffentlichen interesses und pazifist ja
sind sie unterbricht
nein ich habe an der zukunft ein sehr
reduziertes interesse haben thomas morus
übersetzt ja genau ich hab' ich habe
thomas morus übersetzt aber da ist das
faszinierendste die vorstellung vom ende
des geldes zu denken also zu denken was
wäre wenn wir nicht ein tausch
verhältnissen dieser acht leben würden
und es gibt diese rührende stelle bei
moores wo die gesellschaft aus dem von
der nachbarinsel kommt und die haben das
gold abgeschafft nur die sklaven tragen
noch gold und dann kommt die delegation
begrüßt erstmal die sklaven weil sie
denken das sind die wichtigen die
wirklich wichtigen tragen kein gold mehr
und da sieht man das ist ja das ist ja
aus dem früh sozialismus sind diese
utopien also 16 17 und den cup
campanella götter zu welchen gehört dazu
und so also diese ersten gedanken
darüber wie wir leben könnten also
dieses große leben im konjunktiv sich
auszudenken die sind überholt ich glaube
nicht mehr dass wir ein system jenseits
des bestehenden noch erleben werden aber
sie sind narkotisieren etwas was was das
potenzial angeht indem er gedacht wird
darf ist hier als abschluss des
gesprächs bieten sich selbst eine frage
zu stellen
mehr glauben sie eigentlich wer sie sind
sie haben gesagt sie soll die formel 1
entflammt
mehr fällt mir nicht ein eine emsland
ein vermittler ja er will uns in vielen
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen herr steiner
[Musik]